hey I'm talking about you you're
choosing the traditional
the things that like you say traditional
women supposed to do the the clothes the
food the cooking the caring for your
mind and everything but
then you've got the modern side which
the traditional woman wouldn't do but
then when it suits you
then you're using the ring to show
people like you know what
and that is exactly what he was saying
ages ago yeah that's exactly what he was
saying now if you turned around and said
yes I wear all these skimpy clothes and
I go out I'm on my knee trust me and I
wear the wedding ring as extra it would
have made a big difference to how I
perceived you that's me then sorry for
not saying that it would have made a it
would have made a big difference but the
Auntie that is me because I want to
drink what I want and where I want you
know what I'm trying to say is that and
I'll wear this what I'm trying to say is
that you can't have it you can't have it
all
obviously you know that a wedding ring
makes a big difference otherwise you
wouldn't wear it I've got a caveat wait
a minute let me speak to Auntie for a
second but why can't I with the wedding
ring the fake wedding ring go out and
wear what I want and feel comfortable
and dance and that's even worse but I
don't I don't want people to touch me so
if I've got the uh is that is that good
or bad hang in a minute when so when
people are going out and you've got the
wedding ring is there a chance that they
will try and touch you of course there's
always a chance so have anybody ever
touched you when you go out without your
wedding ring of course
of course it's the fact that I still
have the boyfriend that lets me go out
and do what I want to do but I'll
connect you but you're an independent
woman he lets you because he feels
comfortable with me doing that if he
didn't then it'd be a different story
but he still feels so comfortable with
me going out wearing what am I want
drinking the tequila wearing what I want
one and all that stuff so if he didn't
you wouldn't know if he didn't it would
be a different story your boyfriend's
Simpkins
what I want to get to is that
when you put the ring on what situations
do you feel that you're in I just feel
more that you need to put it on like
give us a scenario you're going out tell
us where you are what you're wearing
what you're doing and when you decide to
put the ring always brick caveat I won't
say be honest because I know from a from
a man she's already said mace don't stop
a geyser does it it doesn't it doesn't
stop a guy but the thing is I could go
out in a tracksuit going to the shop
there's a guy that's going to try it
with me or I could go out and a skimpy
outfit in a club and dance how I want to
dance he's going to still try with me so
from me going out of course it's gonna
fight in the church now you said the
shop thing would you wear the ready ring
to go to the shop if you knew you're
going to get hit on no of course right
so you wear it you wear it if you know
you're going to get hit on the necklace
why is she going out into a hostile
environment oh so I want to have fun I
wanna in a hospital environment am I
supposed to stay at home Auntie am I
supposed to sit home no is this what
modern women modern women okay if we're
going on this yeah they're supposed to
stay at home so their men can go out do
what they want but you can't you've got
to stay at home just in case men are
gonna move to you
who said that is that what you believe
traditional women do that's what I'm
asking that's what I'm asking is that
what traditionally no because that's no
traditional women they go out um
they enjoy themselves safely and they do
not go into hostile environments
[Music]
in this day and age everywhere is
hostile
wait a minute let Auntie speak I'll tell
you where I go I go to shows I go to
festivals it's a Godiva Festival I go to
festivals I go to theaters I go to shows
I will go and I would concerts listen to
music and that is where I go there's no
music I can't go to a club anymore then
Auntie no I didn't say that you couldn't
go to a club environment if you want to
put yourself why would it's not logical
why would you want to put yourself in a
hostile environment the word is in there
everywhere
wait let me finish it's not everywhere
because I go out regular and I don't go
in hostile environments okay
why would you say why would you go into
an environment that you say is hostile
because I still want to have fun and it
doesn't matter how I where I want to
have fun it doesn't matter them hostile
environments is the places I want to
have fun so the model I'm not asking
them to be in hostile I could go to a
club and have friends like a dance with
my friends but it's still going to be
hostile because the people there are
making a hostile like where where do I
go have fun if the places I want to have
fun guys are making it hostile guys are
making up hang on a minute so what is in
these environments
I want to know where is it that you go
what makes it hostile and what what
happens there men no what happens there
the men where do you go I could go I
want right tell me where you go first we
need to have fun I'm gonna go have fun
with my friends of a group of girls I
want to go dance hang a minute I just
want to just want to take it
you want to go out with your friends
friends one female friends female
friends yeah you want to go and dance
dance yeah I Wanna Dance yep I want to
drink yeah I wanna wear what I want to
want
but then in these places there are the
guys that make it a hostile environment
yeah so if the same places that I want
to do the things where I want to dance I
want to listen to music I want to listen
to on a drink what I want to drink but
the guys are there that make it hostile
where do I go tell me where I want to go
no tell me some places those things that
you like yeah that you can't find them
anywhere else but in a hostile
environment no no because like guys are
there like Mason said earlier places of
so you could go somewhere before and
things could be so chilled Good Vibes
whatever but now it's changed so what
should I stop going to the place yes yes
yes yes
wait for me you're stopping me wait a
minute we're not talking about the a guy
or having a man I'm just mean in general
the place is being hostile why should I
have to change what I like because I
like house music and I like going to
house festivals and we are why should I
not go we are now because there's guys
there at hospital yeah I've been to this
house first there's festivals out there
that are not hospitals
there's these hostile environments women
are going to the environments and
they're hostile the men out there are
hostile the men are making it hostile
why the women go in because they love it
where do we go
things have changed so much
attention you do you do because because
you've got Jamie Jones headline and
that's what you do you do you do I've
just listen I'm just listening wait a
minute I've just listened to you women
tell me about going into hostile dangers
I've listened to you that was your words
we didn't put those words in your mouth
you said hostile you talked about all
these different things that had it in
there and now you want to talk about do
you realize if the place is hostile is
dangerous for for me as a man I've been
um I've been stabbed before I know what
it feels like so when you guys are
talking about hostile environments I'm
listening to you you guys have no idea
what it is when you get in a real
hostile environment the dangers of it so
you're telling me about a place where
it's dangerous I'm not talking about I'm
not talking about somewhere where it's
just you know something might have it's
hostile the word hostile means dangerous
let me carry on let me carry on let me
carry on and the only thing you want to
tell me is oh um like there's no other
place you can go there's so many places
in the world you can go you I like wait
a minute wait a minute wait a minute you
guys do not mitigate risk you as women
do not mitigate risks you treat every
risk is the same not all risk is the
same and this is why you get yourself
put in scenarios you're going to a place
where the Mana grab you grabby grabby
the man don't know how to act have me
raised right but yet you still want to
go then when something bad happens you
want to start crying and then you've got
a man at home wait a minute who told you
but you man at home I said babe why did
you put yourself in that scenario
we go for the music I'm sorry if my
favorite DJ's there I want to go and I
want to listen to that music why should
I not go because guys aggressive China
Dubai yeah as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider are sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible